Corpus Juris ad hominem to kokway
post-hoc Ergo propter Hawk
I know all of these things and it's so
hard to say every once in a while a
genius changes the legal landscape
forever sometimes that genius isn't even
a lawyer and Scholars will look back on
history as the days before the onion
file the supreme court brief and the
days after
because we
all changed now it's not surprising
because according to the onion supreme
court brief the onion Rose from its
humble beginnings as a print newspaper
in 1756 and now enjoys a daily
readership of 4.3 trillion and has grown
into the single most powerful and
influential organization in human
history yes the onion has filed its
first ever Amicus brief and it started
with the top the U.S Supreme Court its
brief immediately took law Twitter by
storm and I've read a lot of briefs in
my time and trust me they are not all as
funny and precise as this one and people
have asked if real lawyers were actually
involved in this particular brief yes
the authors of this momentous brief the
onions head writer Mike Gillis and the
onions lawyers of record Stephen J van
stempfort and D Andrew portinga who are
real people I actually checked on that
pulled no punches in their brief writing
quote The Onion knows that the federal
Judiciary is staffed entirely by total
Latin dorks they quote catalysts in the
Original Latin and Chambers they sweetly
whisper Starry decisis to their spouse's
ears they mutter kui Bono under their
breath while picking up after their
neighbor's dogs so the the onion knew
that unless it pointed to a suitably
Latin rallying cry its brief would be
operating far outside the Court's
vernacular I feel so seen but the
question must be asked is this a great
supreme court brief or the greatest
supreme court brief in history but first
we have to ask ourselves why is the
onion filing a friend of the court brief
with the Supreme Court well they're
standing up for Anthony Novak an Ohio
man who started mocking his local police
department in March of 2016. Novak's
Facebook page had the same name cover
photo and profile photo as the Parma
Police Department's official page but it
was designated a community page and
didn't have the official blue check mark
verifying it as an official page Novak's
page displayed the satirical slogan we
know crime now Parma is Cleveland Ohio's
biggest suburb and it has long had a
reputation for being just a little bit
extra and by that I mean it has a
well-documented problem with racism in
the 1970s the justice department
concluded that parma's near manic growth
was a classic example of white flight
the doj found that the City of Parma
engaged in a pattern practice of racial
discrimination in housing in violation
of the Fair Housing Act of 1968 and the
city didn't settle with the doj until
1998. the Parma police department has
been cited for refusing to hire minority
police officers Cleveland is 51 black
its largest suburb is still less than 5
percent black and I'll note
parenthetically that one of the members
of Team legal eagle is from Cleveland
and informs me that department police
are notorious for prosecuting drivers
for driving while black now legendary
Public Access host googleardi father of
director Paul Thomas Anderson
relentlessly mocked Parma for decades
Anthony Novak clearly knew this history
when he set out to mock the local cops
as Cleveland magazine once said quote
everyone in the country makes fun of
Cleveland and everyone in Cleveland
makes fun of Parma now Novak's page was
up for six hours and during that time it
published six satirical posts the first
was an apology for quote failing to
inform the public about an armed robbery
of a Subway sandwich shot by a white man
while requesting information to quote
bring to Justice in African-American
women woman who was loitering in front
of the shop during the robbery Novak
then published a fake announcement that
new police officers would be recruited
based on a quote 15 question multiple
choice definition test followed by a
hearing test and strongly encouraged
minorities to not apply he followed up
with an update about a pedophile reform
event promising that anyone who made it
through the stations would be removed
from the sex offender registry and
accepted as an honorary police officer
Now by now you are probably thinking
that surely everyone who saw these Pages
knew it was a parody and of course was
protected by the First Amendment but
that's not how the Parma police saw it
they got a few phone calls from confused
citizens they immediately posted a
warning on the police department's Real
Page letting people know that the other
page was fake and that the department
was investigating the comments to the
notice reveal that most citizens
understood what was happening now Novak
thought it would be funny to post the
police notice on his page verbatim so
that's what he did Officer Kevin Riley
didn't like that and so he went on the
local news where he said that the cops
were launching an investigation into the
Page's own uh Riley described the pages
quote but frankly they're crude they're
demeaning and they're very inflammatory
Our concern right now is Public Safety
now as legally idiotic as those
statements were Riley's comments did
prompt Novak to take his page down but
Department of officials did not let up
instead the police subpoenaed Facebook
to unmask Novak the page wasn't even up
by the time that they discovered Novak's
identity now once they knew it was Novak
they consulted with the prosecutor
Timothy dilbeck dobek and the officers
searched for a crime to fit this
situation and ultimately landed on Ohio
Revised Code section 2909.04 b a felony
statute prohibiting The Knowing quote
use of any computer to disrupt interrupt
or impair the functions of any police
operation now how did Novak disrupt the
police department his parity caused 11
people to call up the station in
confusion but that was enough for a
local magistrate who founded the cops
had probable cause to search Novak's
house the police then conducted a SWAT
raid on Novak's home confiscating his
gaming consoles computers and tablets
police arrested Novak and threw him in
jail for four days
detective Thomas Connor told the grand
jury that the callers quote honest to
God actually believed the page was real
the grand jury indicted Novak for
disrupting Public Services a fourth
degree felony that carried a maximum
penalty of 18 months in prison but not
surprisingly later during a deposition
Conor admitted that none of the callers
thought the parody Facebook page was
real but the damage was done the city
continues to insist to this day that 10
of those calls wasted precious dispatch
time but let's be real
Parma dispatchers probably get more
useless phone calls when Rudy strudel
runs out of donuts on Packy day I guess
that's a Cleveland joke now uh Novak
stood trial and uh lucky for him the
jury acquitted him and after he was
acquitted he then sued the City of Parma
the police department and the police
officers for violating his civil rights
because that's exactly what they did the
police officers not surprisingly raised
qualified immunity as a defense now I've
talked about qualified immunity in the
past but here's a recap of this
judicially invented Doctrine qualified
immunity protects State officials from
being held accountable on a federal
level for violating a person's
constitutional rights under this
Doctrine an officer or state actor is
immune from civil liability if a court
has not previously stated that the
officer's Act was unconstitutional in a
prior Court decision it's an idea that
if there isn't a court decision on this
type of constitutional violation then
they don't have notice that they were
violating someone's constitutional
rights now qualified immunity only
allows lawsuits to move forward if State
officials violated a quote clearly
established statutory or constitutional
right and when determining whether or
not a right was clear established courts
consider whether a hypothetical
reasonable officer would have known that
the defendant's conduct violated the
plaintiff's rights what started as a way
to ensure that officials were not held
liable for things that they had no way
of knowing were unconstitutional has now
become really a serious impediment for
holding police officers accountable the
federal district court for northern Ohio
denied the Parma officer's motion for
qualified immunity but the sixth circuit
eventually overturned that decision the
Court held it was not clearly
established that Novak's copying of the
Department's notice onto his page and
the deletion of user comments were
protected speech under the disruption
statute quote the officers could
reasonably believe that some of Novak's
Facebook activity was not parody not
protected and fair grounds for probable
cause the sixth circuit put Special
Value on the fact that a prosecutor and
magistrate agreed that there was
probable cause that Novak violated the
statute now with that somewhat
depressing background in mind we can
turn to how in the world does this
involve the onion well when someone
files an amicus brief they have to start
by stating why they have an interest in
the case that the court should consider
so the brief starts out by discussing
the interests of the Amicus the Friend
of the Court in this case the onion
quote the onion is the world's leading
news publication offering highly
acclaimed universally revered coverage
of breaking national International and
local news events quote the onion's Keen
fact-driven reportage has been cited
favorably by one or more local courts as
well as Iran and the Chinese state-run
media now I love this part because it
goes to the heart of what makes good
parity the ability of the satirist to
actually make people think it might be
real and the onion has tricked many
people into reporting its stories as
fact and back in 2012 Iran's fars news
agency published a story claiming that a
Gallup poll found that rural white
Americans preferred Iranian president
Mahmoud Ahmadinejad over President
Barack Obama although that feels like it
might have been true unfortunately
Ahmadinejad was ineligible for U.S
presidency so we'll never know if his
stance about women covering their hair
would have gained Traction in rural
Indiana though I were free that it would
Chinese State media also thought that
the onion story declaring Kim Jong-un
the sexiest man alive was real the onion
wrote that Kim was quote blessed with an
air of power that masks an unmistakably
cute cuddly side Kim made this
newspaper's editorial board Swoon with
his impeccable fashion sense short
hairstyle and of course that famous
smile well look when you put it that way
it's easy to see why the 45th president
had such a crush now the onion brief
also points out that it has a good track
record of predicting future events quote
one such coup was the onion scoop
revealing that a former president kept
nuclear secrets strewn around his Beach
home's basement three years before it
even happened fact check true now the
onion really did write a story in 2017
about the nuclear briefcase being left
behind at Mar-A-Lago noting that it had
already been there for almost two weeks
Mar-A-Lago assistant manager Chris
Mahoney reportedly wondered if anyone
was coming to collect the nuclear
briefcase from the club's lost and found
anyway the onion filed this brief to
protect the rights of parody creators
who as a class would prefer not to be
arrested for being funny quote The Onion
files this brief to protect its
continued ability to create fiction that
may ultimately merge into reality as the
globe's premier paradists the onions
writers also have a self-serving
interest in preventing political
authorities from imprisoning humorists
this brief is submitted in the interest
of at least mitigating their future
punishment and the brief zeroes in on
the six circuits holding the paradist
would not be protected unless they let
the audience in on the joke by warning
them that their parody is not true the
onion notes that quote some forms of
Comedy don't work unless the comedian is
able to tell the joke with a straight
face parody is the quintessential
example Paradis intentionally inhabit
the rhetorical form of their Target in
order to exaggerate or implode it and by
doing so demonstrate the target's
illogic or absurdity now the hilarity of
the brief is an example of the thing it
seeks to protect an ultra serious take
on a real thing that by its nature will
fool some people or as the onions
lawyers put it quote for parity to work
it has to plausibly mimic the original
and as the onion points out in its brief
quote two stultis s you are dumb these
Latin words have been the onions motto
and Guiding Light since it was founded
in 1988 as America's Finest news source
leading its writers toward the paper's
singular purpose of pointing out that
its readers are deeply gullible people
and they're not just crapping on their
own audience they're making an important
point the quote tricking readers into
believing that they're seeing a serious
rendering of some specific form a pop
song lyric a newspaper article a police
beat and then allowing them to laugh at
their own Guild ability when they
realize that they've Fallen victim to
one of the oldest tricks in the history
of rhetoric and despite the literal
falsity of parody and satire it
literally has to be false to work it
enjoys first amendment protection as it
should and when assessing whether
satirical speech is defamation the
courts consider what a reasonable reader
would have understood the author to have
said not the literal meaning of the
words and the capacity to fool the
audience is essential so in other words
a person Billy no you can't be up here
so in other words a person doesn't have
to publish a disclaimer that the writing
is fake that would ruin the joke imagine
how it would have ruined the punchline
of Jonathan Swift's a modest proposal
which argued with a straight face that
the starving Irish should just eat their
own babies and if you're worried about
the onion being humble and comparing
itself to Jonathan Swift well you don't
need to be they write quote to be clear
the audience is not trying to compare
itself to Jonathan Swift its writers are
far more talented and their output will
be read long after that hack Swifts has
been lost to the sands of time still the
onion and its Riders share with swift
the common goal of replicating a form
precisely in order to critique it from
within and as the onion points out
Swift's goals was the same to replicate
the form the boring economic paper in
order to critique it from within and
that's why the full title of Swift's
paper was a modest proposal for
preventing the children of poor people
from being a burden to their parents or
country and for making them beneficial
to the public and the onion Riders do
this every day to hilarious effect the
brief points to an onion article titled
quote the Supreme Court rules Supreme
Court rules which is meant to mimic the
form of the Associated Press it starts
with the sentence in a landmark decision
Monday the United States Supreme Court
ruled eight to one that it rules and the
onion follows the Associated Press form
straight through into the article it
says quote Justice Anthony Kennedy
writing on behalf of the majority noted
that quote while the U.S Constitution
guarantees a quality of power among the
executive legislative and judicial
branches it most definitely does not
guarantee equality of coolness and in
this regard the judicial branch kicks
that which can be construed as total and
complete ass so the power of the parody
rises from that dissonance into which
the reader has been drawn and the onions
brief argues that because parody mimics
the real thing and has even more power
to critique the real thing quote Paradis
can take apart an authoritarian Cult of
Personality point out the rhetorical
tricks that politicians use to mislead
their constituents and even undercut
governments institutions real world
attempts at propaganda for the onion
this has worked time and time again
since his articles tend to expose
leaders who have no ability to
distinguish facts from fiction the brief
singles out one of them Republican
congressman John Fleming Who quote
believed that he needed to warn his
constituents of a dangerous escalation
of the pro-choice movement after reading
the onions headline Planned Parenthood
opens eight billion abortion Plex of
course Yelp reviewers got in on the gag
and reviewed the fake Kansas abortion
Plex which convinced other readers that
this was a real thing and quote we
taxpayers were paying for it the
legendary abortion Plex story is still
fooling people in 2022 and although the
brief tongue-in-cheek called onion
reader stupid it backtracks on that
claim and explained the mental capacity
of reasonable readers Who quote do not
need to be told explicitly what they
have no serious trouble figuring out for
themselves in the brief notes that the
Supreme Court has already indicated that
disclaimers aren't needed they referred
to a footnote of the opinion of Campbell
versus a cuff Rose which of course was a
very famous fair use case where the
dispute was about whether the rap group
two Live Crew had a right to publish a
parody of Roy orbison's Pretty Woman and
in that case the court said that two
Live Crew need not label their whole
album or even the song a parody in order
to claim fair use protection nor should
two Live Crew be penalized for this
being its first prodic essay
[Music]
parody serves its goals whether labeled
or not and there's no reason to require
parody to State the obvious or even the
reasonably perceived and the onion
argues convincingly that the six
circuits holding is contrary to the case
law the Court ruled that the Parma cops
quote could reasonably believe that some
of Novak's Facebook activity was not
parody primarily because Mr Novak
deleted comments that made clear the
page was fake but the brief argues that
the lack of explicit disclaimer makes no
difference to whether a reasonable
reader would discern that this speech
was parody and the onion takes issue
with the sixth circuits view that the
search warrant insulates the police from
liability since other authority figures
also shared the same wrong-headed view
of free speech quote this was not a
close call on the facts Mr Novak's spoof
Facebook post advertised at the Parma
Police Department was hosting a
pedophile reform event in which
successful participants could be removed
from the sex offender registry and
become honorary members of the
department after completing puzzles and
quizzes that the department had
discovered an experimental technique for
abortions and would be providing them to
teens for free in a police van that the
department was soliciting job applicants
but the minorities were quote strongly
encouraged not to apply and that the
department was Banning City residents
from feeding homeless people in quote an
attempt to have the homeless population
eventually leave our city due to
starvation so yeah you'd have to be
pretty dumb to think that the Facebook
posts were real and also criminal Novak
can't help it if a Magistrate Judge and
City attorney are closer to the lowest
common denominator than the average
reasonable reader and the idea also
argues that Paradis should not be
prosecuted for telling jokes now this
seems self-explanatory so the onion
lawyers crafted a couple paragraphs just
to keep your attention quote this is the
15th page of a convoluted legal filing
intended to deconstruct the societal
implications of parity so the reader's
attention is almost certainly wandering
that's understandable so here's a
paragraph of gripping legal analysis to
ensure that every jurist who reads this
brief is appropriately impressed by the
logic of its argument and the Lucidity
of its prose Bona vacantia de bonus
aspartatus rich
Forum non-convenience Corpus Juris ad
hominem to kokway post-hoc Ergo propter
Hawk
I know all of these things and so hard
to say quote EST demonstratum actus
Reyes scandulum magnatum pakdum
reservati domini see what happened this
brief itself went from a discussion of
parody's function in the quite serious
historical and legal arguments in favor
of strong protections for parotic speech
to a curveball mocking the way legalese
can be both impenetrably boring and
belie the hollowness of a legal position
that's the setup and punchline idea
again it would not have worked quite as
well if this brief it said the following
hello there reader we're about to write
an amicus brief about the value of
parity buckle up because we're going to
be doing some fairly outright things
including commenting on this text form
itself so yeah it's not good to punish
funny people for saying funny things
even if those things may be offensive
and the onion promises to quote continue
with socially valuable role bringing the
disinfective son light into the halls of
power and it would vastly prefer that
sunlight not be measured out to its
riders in 15-minute increments in an
exercise yard and this YouTube channel
agrees now normally a lawyer's
conclusion is a pretty dry summary of
what they want the court to do but here
the onion aims high once again quote the
petition for sure I should be granted
the rights of the people Vindicated and
various historical wrongs remedied the
onion would welcome any of the three
particularly the first so what happens
next well the Supreme Court will decide
whether to take Novak's case or not and
potentially overturn the sixth circuit's
decision if it does not then the sixth
circuit decision remains good law
despite it being bad law but you'll be
able to read all about the Supreme
Court's next decision in today's sponsor
morningbrew because that's my favorite
way to catch up with pop culture and the
news in fact you could have already
learned about the onions brief because
they covered it and I read it in my
email I've actually been subscribed to
morningbrew for forever it's one of my
absolute favorite newsletters and I'm
thrilled to tell you why because morning
Brew if you didn't know already is a
free daily newsletter delivered Monday
through Sunday it gets you up to speed
on business finance Tech and law in just
five minutes and provides a fantastic
quick summary of the most important
issues while being witty irreverent and
informative and did I mention it's
completely free this week I learned all
about how Elon Musk actually bought
Twitter for real this time how Kanye
West was getting denounced by everyone
and why Matt Damon killed everyone's
investment returns it's basically
exactly the mix of news that I'm
actually interested in and stuff that I
didn't even know I wanted to know about
and it's all written in a hilarious
style morning Brew is one of the few
emails that I actually open every day so
Legal Eagles this one is a complete
no-brainer morning Brew is completely
free and it takes less than 15 seconds
to subscribe just click on the link
that's on screen right now or in the
description to get morning Brew for free
and not only will you get a newsletter
that you'll actually read you'll
actually help out this channel too so
click on the link below to get morning
Brew right away and after you sign up
you should click over here on this
playlist to watch more legal eagle or
I'll see you in court